[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique avec une question aujourd'hui
à quand la gratuité des transports
scolaires pour tous les enfants de
franche comté et de bourgogne le
transport scolaire est une des nouvelles
compétences de la région transférer des
départements la gratuité était un
engagement de campagne de marie-guite
dufay mais pour autant à la rentrée
prochaine ne concernera que 6
départements sur 8 les familles de
l'yonne et de la nièvre qui paient
continueront à payer
rajoutons un transfert tumultueux avec
la haute-saône rajoutons aussi que la
situation n'est pas la même non plus
pour les enfants des villes pour en
débattre et pour comprendre comment se
déroulent ces transferts et cette
harmonisation nous avait invités hélène
pélissard bonjour bonjour conseiller
régional l'est républicain vous êtes
vice présidente de la commission des
transports michel neugnot bonjour
bonjour premier vice président
socialiste du conseil régional en charge
des transports vous présidez aussi par
ailleurs la commission mobilité
transports à l'association des régions
de france
marie-claude qu'au coin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la présidente de la fcpe
parents d'élèves de la nièvre un
département où les transports ne seront
toujours payant à la prochaine rentrée
rajoutons que le groupe front national
n'a pas répondu à nos sollicitations à
débat diffusé en simultané sur facebook
sur la page de france 3 bourgogne de
france 3 franche comté vous pouvez
intervenir commenter ce débat et on
pourra citer vos remarques
je disais pour commencer c'est un des
effets de la loi notre la région devient
l'autorité organisatrice des transports
non urbain en général et donc des
transports scolaires on se dit à
première vue allen pélissard que jude
loin c'est-à-dire lui département et
position centrale ça risque d'être moins
bien est ce que c'est une bonne idée des
transports scolaires à la région écoutez
la mobilité et transports scolaires sont
pour nos territoires ruraux pour nous
huit départements ruraux un enjeu
capital
effectivement et nous avons des bassins
de vie qui sont grands nous avons des
regroupements scolaires qui ont été
effectués des temps de transport qui
sont l'eau pour les enfants il est donc
nécessaire d'avoir
un travail de proximité un travail dans
la dentelle
et moi je pense personnellement et
l'ensemble du groupe auquel j'appartiens
pense aussi que pour un travail de
proximité une collectivité de proximité
était ce qui pouvait exister de mieux et
le département bien évidemment été cette
connectivité bien je vous donne un
exemple tout simple en ce moment il fait
assez froid dans nos départements il ya
de la neige la voirie et le déneigement
reste une compétence du département et
le transport scolaire pour le moment et
encore compétences du département mais
va être transféré il est plus facile de
régler des problèmes dans une même
collectivité
lorsque la voirie doit parler aux
transports scolaires les bureaux sont à
côté les agents se connaissent si il y à
un conflit
le directeur général ou président du
conseil départemental tranche les choses
sont simples elles sont fluides
nous n'aurons pas nous n'aurons pas
cette même transparence avec l'av
la réforme va voir maintenant michel
neugnot vous allez me dire que la région
c'est forcément mieux que le département
vu que c'est vous qui le récupère et ou
pas forcément réalité bien je prends
l'argument d' hélène pélissard
on peut exactement suivre ce
raisonnement en disant que n'avoir plus
sur le territoire que deux autorités
organisatrices de transport à savoir les
agglos pour tous les transforme à terre
au centre de l'agglomération
et pour l'interurbain avoir uniquement
comme autorité organisatrice de
transport la région c'est une
simplification administrative quant à la
proximité
je sais que les élus le pensent toujours
qu'ils sont essentiels
mais la proximité elle assuré déjà par
les conducteurs de bus et par les
accompagnateurs le premier niveau 20
d'un premier intervenant
d'autre part l'organisation que nous
allons maintenir est une organisation
départementale et qui plus est la loi
prévoit qu'il y à transfert des
personnels qui très bien y ait dans le
département est ce son
85,80 équivalents temps plein que nous
allons récupérer qui vont être base est
toujours dans les chefs lieux de
département et quand les départements
sont d'accord qui vont être localisés
dans des bâtiments du département donc
effectivement il ya deux logiques hélène
la logique de dire
routes et transports du quotidien orange
entre et puis à la logique de dire que
tout les problèmes de mobilité réduit à
deux autorités organisatrices de
transport c'est aussi une simplification
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a eu
au moment où on a voté la loi était en
débat
marylise lebranchu souhaitait que les
routes soient tc transférer fait aussi
transféré pour 5 e rang ça n'a pas été
le cas donc deux cohérence différentes
mais je pense que d'avoir deux autorités
sur le territoire ce qui n'empêche pas
de travailler avec les nouvelles grandes
intercommunalités dans le milieu rural
et qui permet de pallier ce léger
raccompagnant été signé à paris un pénis
live votre coin du point de vue des
parents d'élèves
alors même si tout le monde s'est pas
encore d'ailleurs qu'il ya un transfert
en réalité vers la région on le verra
tout à l'heure il ya quoi il ya une
forme d'espoir dans votre département
vers resterez venir mais d'inquiétudes
en se disant ça va être piloté très très
loin vous êtes dans la nièvre est un
département très excentré aussi par
rapport au coeur de la région
c'est quoi la tendance alors je dirais
qu'il ya les deux il ya d'abord l'espoir
de la gratuité bien sûr que pour nous
des moyens financiers qui peuvent
couvrir le coût des transports scolaires
des parents c'est quelque chose qu'on
attend avec impatience c'est vraiment
pour nous un apport important c'est ce
coup financier qui pourrait aider la
nièvre et d'un autre côté c'est
l'inquiétude effectivement par rapport à
la proximité
les enfants qui enfin les transports
scolaires sur tout le département c'est
vrai qu'on a un interlocuteur on le
connaît il connaît très bien département
on a on a très vite
effectivement la possibilité de les
joindre et
2 en discuter et d'attirer l'attention
sur ce qui ne va pas ce qu'il faut que
les gens comprennent bien c'est qu'il ya
un transfert un transfert général lnt
lissar le transfert c'est les gens
l'argent l'argent qui a été investi
jusque là le matériel c'est tout ça dans
un département vers la région
oui c'est tout ça et c'est pour ça c'est
pourquoi quand j'entends michel neugnot
me dire mais ça va très bien se passer
parce que de toute façon on reprend le
transport mais ça ne change rien nous
dire vous venez de nous dire ça ne
change rien ça reste dans les
départements
rien ne va changer mais si ça va changer
ça va changer parce que le lien de
subordination des personnels qui seront
dans le département il ne sera plus avec
les responsables du département il met
responsable de la région obligatoirement
y aura deux compétences de deux
administrations différentes qui devront
se parler et bien évidemment ça sera
plus compliqué mais bon c'est la loi on
va pas revenir dessus
la loi notre goût le jura ça s'est bien
passé
le transfert mais je les dirai michel
neugnot en séance et je lui redis
aujourd'hui
sur le plan financier le transfert avec
la région s'est plutôt bien passé on a
su parler la claire tu as su définir à
peu près quel était le coût du transport
et il n'y a rien à dire de ce côté là -
le souci que j'ai aujourd'hui celle
opérationnel au niveau financier
on a été je pense les uns les autres des
élus responsables et nous avons trouvé
les solutions
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas trouvé avec
tous vos ennemis dans certains
départements les mêmes facilités dans
des la perche pour dire à michel neugnot
effectivement que vous prenez l'exemple
du jura mais qui a par exemple exemple
la haute saône qui est gelée qualifié
tumultueux tout à l'heure le transfert
on peut le qualifier
si vous voulez ya six mois quand on
parlait de cela on dirait que transfert
n'était impossible à faire il a une
pélissard vial de le dire dans sept
départements sur huit
cela s'est fait ces dits dangereux seul
dans sept départements sur huit cela
s'est fait par un accord un accord qui
ait été validé et qui a raté un principe
simple continuité du service public et
neutralité financière pour tous les
intervenants
il y a un département avec lequel nous
avons quelques difficultés la loi est
plutôt bien fait puisque la prévenir ni
trash qui a été rendue maintenant il
prêchait ce préfet clairvivre c'est le
préfet qui arbitre maintenant il faut
que cet objectif de d'avoir la
continuité du service public et bien
préval par rapport à toutes les autres
considérations
marie-claude coin vous comprenez aussi
que votre département la nièvre
transfert puisqu'elle ne pratiquait pas
la gratuité prend faire moins d'argent à
la région du coup c'est toujours
compliqué pour nous qu'on n'a pas
souvent les toute l'histoire
on connaît pas toute l'histoire en ski
ce qui s'est passé entre nos
départements et la région
donc nous c'est on va parler de ça un
petit peu en on va dire d'un d'un on est
très jeune très éloigné du sujet nous a
vraiment on est on est les parents de
terrain et et nous ce que l'on veut
c'est que ce transfert se fasse
l'historique est compliqué ce qu'on nous
dit certainement pas tous hein et puis
en plus on va pas toutes les réunions on
est on a on a quand même où on n'est pas
tout à fait intégrés dedans on va dire
oui vous n'avez pas été partie prenante
dans le transfert du tout nous a perdu
tout demander notre avis donc voilà
arrivé un moment où on est on est devant
le fait accompli on nous dit ben voilà
sur les huit départements de la nièvre
qu'ils ne passeraient pas gratuit donc
vous comprenez notre compris en fin de
trac compréhension et notre identité
c'est pas normal quoi qu'elle est enfin
au bout d'un moment le foot c'est le
droit des usagers face aux services
publics l'égalité là il y en a pas je
pense que c'est grave ce qui se passe et
nous on veut absolument être comme les
autres de sa nounou département la
nièvre et l'yonne son département qui on
peut pas dire sont riches
on a besoin d'autres activités cette
attractivité si on veut accueillir
d'autres parents c'est vraiment celle là
de faire comme tout alors on va on a
posé la question
une policière le par rapport à ça vous
vouliez quelque chose à noter lissar pas
ce que je vais faire rebondir justement
ce regard du thé mais on en a ras le jeu
vous propose de vous allez pouvoir dire
ce que vous voulez après ce qu'on va
diffuser tout de suite qu'ils sont des
questions qu'on a posés on est allé voir
les habitants de bourgogne franche comté
comme petite tablette en leur posant des
questions justement sur les transports
scolaires et sur la gratuité vous allez
voir sur la gratuité il ya une forme de
quasi unanimité
regardez écoutez
savez-vous qui gère les transports
scolaires non j'en ai strictement aucune
idée conseil départemental
les départements je crois
normalement c'est la région conseil
régional je pense que c'est la vie que
les besoins sont jamais à 81 2 angers
puis temps forts ils sont pas là alors
je machine là ça les transports
scolaires doivent-ils être gratuit non
non il faut participer et tout le monde
doit participer non à l'écran je pense
que c'est effectivement une bonne chose
qu'ils soient gratuits
parce que comme ça là ça permettrait
aussi aux gens qu'il ait favorisé deux
ici tout se transforme très important
surtout quand il est enfant que c'est
parce que il ya les gens sont de plus en
plus éloignés des villes donc il ya des
transports ça fera moins de voitures sur
la route y ait eu des bus est
l'éducation c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'important et qu'il court pascal
dommage que certains élèves ne puissent
pas aller à l'école faute de moyens pour
des transports scolaires les transports
scolaires style est gratuit bas dans
l'idéal oui sauf que ce serait enfin
prêt c'est quand même difficile pour la
région peut-être d'assumer mais oui ça
serait l'idéal
alors vous venez de l'entendre cheniaux
vêtements pourquoi la nièvre et l'yonne
ne seront pas en gratuit à la rentrée
2010 est alors que marie-guite dufay s'y
était engagé vous organiserez une
émission préventive parce que je vous
rappelle quand même que le transfert de
compétence des transports scolaires
c'est le 1er septembre 2010 est la
rentrée prises le préparer conjointement
entre les services de la région et des
services des huit départements donc 1er
janvier 1er septembre 2010 est il n'y a
pas de changement et cela se comprend
bien
ensuite nous avons une trajectoire qui
est à établir comme vous le disiez fort
justement madame qu'il ya égalité sur le
territoire sur les territoires parce que
les territoires sont différents des uns
et des autres et c'est une opposition
par département c'est une opposition de
caractéristiques de départements
actuellement
actuellement tous les transports
scolaires qui sont gérés par les agglos
et pour lesquels lire les départements
contribuer au financement d'une partie
pas de la totalité les parents d'élèves
paye parce qu'il n'ya pas c'est ce que
nous a dit laurent sur internet et ce
matin il n'y a pas de grand dijon n'y a
pas de vrai les enfants du grand dijon
paye pour ceux qui payent 130 euros
alors de faire en sorte qu'ils ne
comprennent un nom mais je vais vous
il faut comprendre la situation il pèse
130 euros avec un tarif social qui fait
que la contribution moyenne et aux
alentours d'une centaine d'euros
moyennant moyens en moyenne
qu'est ce qu'elle est l'engagement de
camp que nous avons rappelé il y aura
gratuité des transports scolaires hors
frais de dossier et là où nous sommes
compétents aux frais de dossier et là où
nous sommes compétents donc c'est ça que
l'on va décliner est ce que l'on veut
au delà des deux qui paye quoi parce que
quand on part quatre buts et il ya
toujours quelqu'un qui paye c'est
différent d'un département à l'autre on
pourrait peut-être y venir mais ce qui
est important aussi c'est la qualité du
service
or la qualité du service n'est pas de
même nature d'un département à l'autre
je ne dis pas je ne dis pas qu'elle est
mauvaise mais elle est différente on
ajoute jacques sur facebook sur la
taille des bus en disant il envoya des
bus énorme gerbe à rien l'objectif
l'objectif qui est le nôtre l'objectif
qui est le nôtre c'est effectivement on
augmente la qualité du service par le
haut et l'autre un élément que votre
internaute vient de signaler ces
questions se rencontrent je vais pas le
département de l'yonne qui n'avait qui
avait la gratuité à l'endroit où quatre
ans d'ailleurs il n'ya plus avant ce
transfert qu'une bonne vingtaine de
départements en france qu'il n'assume
plus la gratuité totale qui met une
partie de frais de dossier par rapport
aux 100 départements que nous avons donc
ce que nous nous avons comme idc
d'augmenter la qualité du service
partout à caractéristiques de territoire
égal et il n'y a pas que je prenne de
financement si on compte dans la nièvre
vous allez prendre les élèves donnent
une indemnité le département donne une
âme dente même dans un amour quand il ya
un seul élève ce que d'autres
départements n'applique pas avec une
distance plus grands ne pourra pas dans
dans un rayon de 3 km on s'arrête pas et
ce que l'on veut c'est harmonisé par le
haut et faire que sur l'ensemble du
territoire
quand on aura des caractéristiques
identiques à ceux de la nièvre
eh bien on aide les mêmes niveaux de
prestations de l'intérieur monsieur niño
moi je reprends l'engagement nu mais la
proposition numéro 63
de la candidate marie-guite dufay nous
garantirons la gratuité et la qualité
des transports scolaires d'ici la fin du
mandat sur une ligne ou quand on parle
de gratuité
là on ne dit pas gratuite et saufs au
frais d'inscription fred douchet
vêtements pardonnez moi c'est combien
les frais de dossier quand on constate
ce qu'on parle c'est quoi nous sommes en
train de prendre la compétence a donc je
n'allais pas au vista question s'il est
pressé de 0,6 et 40 euros c'est pas la
même chose ici une union vous avez
beaucoup parlé moi je voudrais quand
même rappeler votre engagement
nous avions le même engagement il ya
deux ans gars jean-paul oui il y avait
nous aident et attend nous avions vous
avez pris deux engagements politiques
fortes
le premier c'est la gratuité des
transports mme et vous avez tout à fait
raison madame de le revendiquer
si vous aviez voté pour moi vous auriez
la gratuité des transports
là vous avez fait une erreur mais peint
pas ce que je veux dire vous avez aussi
dit harmonisation général mais heureux
on remet à dijon l'ensemble des
transports s'est notamment gérer les
deux clones de l'exécuter si vous auriez
parfaitement pu laisser les départements
administratifs administrer les
transports scolaires la loi le
permettait sous votre autorité vous
n'avez pas choisi cette solution vous
avez choisi d'organiser totalité des
régions à dire tune la casinca de la
religion en armant dix jours est infér
amour madame miss innover dame en
harmonie non y compris sur une région de
droite une région de gauche la prochaine
il y a deux départements de la manche
qui ont fait le choix délibéré
d'administrer sous couvert l'autorité du
maire josiane département en normandie
je suis un geste au niveau national la
gauche il me reste au niveau national
que 5
département qui gère par délégation donc
géré par délégation la région laisse le
département faisais avant je vous coupe
juste parce que marie-claude co.il
attend gentiment depuis dix minutes pour
nous dire comment ça se passe
actuellement dans la lumière
combien combien cela coûte aux parents
par exemple est-ce que ça on peut le
leur actuellement le coût pour les jeux
vous dire parce que j'ai vraiment vous
sortira ses 97 euros annuellement pour
un parent de la nièvre
voilà donc après il ya ça se décline en
fonction des parents qui sont non
imposables ou il ya une réduction
effectivement de ce montant et ensuite
il est aussi à prendre en compte ce sont
les enfants qui n'ont qui sont en dehors
des cartes scolaires et qui payent plus
cher ce qui est effectivement aussi à
l'intérieur de nos départements on a
encore des frontières parce que nos
enfants ne peuvent pas aller dans tel ou
tel lycée s'ils sont pas laissés de
secteur sur lequel en réalisons encore
en plus les gens là ils ont un coût a en
plus à rajouter à aux transports il faut
savoir que normalement l'école de
gratuite on est on sait sont des valeurs
importantes régions républicaine les
valeurs républicaines que nous portons
sur la gratuité de l'école est loin
d'être gratuite quand on fait le compte
à la fin de l'année de ce que coûtent
les cols à 1 par an entre la
restauration l'internât s'il le faut les
transports les fournitures c'est à ça
que ça vient presque à dire peu près
1000 euros par an pour un enfant donc
imaginer ce qu'ils ont plusieurs enfants
ensuite vous devez revenir sur la guerre
on a effectivement un département qui
est un département rural qui est qui est
très compliqué parce que nous avons
voilà très étendue beaucoup de hameaux
effectivement notre conseil
départemental a certainement beaucoup de
travail et a beaucoup travaillé sur la
qualité des arrêts et ça c'est
effectivement des choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte mais je me dis quand
même une réforme comme ça ça se prépare
ça s'anticipe ça enfin voilà quoi
lorsque nous préparons un budget on
prépare longtemps à l'avancé la loi
notre ses hôtes 2015
on va entrer en 2010 est je pense que le
haut niveau financier obligés financer
ça se prépare en amont il ya une à une
il ya quelque chose qui se travaille en
amont il ya enfin je ne sais pas je
pense qu'il ya une prospective
financière qui doit naître
à partir du moment où on voit de cette
loi dans les régions je ne sais pas
justement je pose la question pourquoi
dès maintenant on se dit ban on ne peut
pas faire pour des raisons
alors avant que michel neugnot répondent
juge juste je vous fait part de quelques
remarques quelqu'un qui nous dit à saint
varent je sais pas dans quel département
ces deux communes monfils 230 euros pour
300 mètres ce qui va beaucoup on nous
fait remarquer qu'il est parfois moins
onéreux d'entretenir un minibus plus
aucun car il ya peut-être là aussi des
économies à faire
mais une autre personne dominique gardy
nous dit attention à la ya pas de
polémique sur la taille des cars parce
que un quart peu transformé 10 élèves à
8 heures alors qu il en contient 50 les
qui va faire une autre sortie plus tard
avec beaucoup plus d'élèves donc les
choses sont loin d'être aussi saf juste
moi je vous pose la question très
simplement michel neugnot
ce qu'on comprend bien c'est quand même
qu' il ya des départements qui demandait
de l'argent par an ce qui vous transfert
c'est moins d'argent
est-ce que de façon très prosaïque la
région bourgogne franche comté et là les
moyens dans des temps prochain de faire
la gratuité pour tous les enfants de
bourgogne et de franche-comté et est-ce
que ça concernera peut-être aussi les
agglomérations ou pas alors on cherche
des saints poussèrent concernant les
agglos nous allons retransféré l'argent
que les départements donnait aux agglo à
l'euro près dont il y aura sur
l'ensemble des agglos la même
tarification que celle que l'on connaît
actuellement
et qui paye sur l'agglo continueront
après qu'il aura payé sur les accords
continuera payer sur les ags alors la
nièvre et l'yonne et la nièvre et
l'yonne ont su ensuite sur le type qui
paye quoi dans les transports il faut
savoir que d'un département à l'autre
c'est totalement différent
vous avez des départements le vote
madame où il n'y ait rien demandé
le jour à l infra départementale dire
c'est c'est le département qui paie tout
vous avez d'autres départements ou les
intercommunalités payent une partie
c'est le cas du vote c'est le cas de la
côte d'or où les communes payent c'est
le cas de la saône et loire
donc vous voyez bien quand on parle de
gratuité je veux préfère savoir et vous
dire qui paye quoi parce que le service
à un coût et le problème est de savoir
qui le paye la position que nous avions
que nous avons est de dire la gratuité
du transport est assuré au fret dauchez
et là où nous sommes compétents donc pas
dans les agglos où il a dix ça ne sera
pas modifiée par contre ailleurs ils
eurent une participation de frais de
dossier qui n'est pas neutre parce
qu'elle permet en même temps un montant
michel neugnot il faut que ce montant il
faut que ce montant d'après la loi soit
ce ne soit pas anecdotique
c'est à dire que il doit représenter une
partie du coût de transport pourquoi
pourquoi parce que cela j'ai précisé
parce que s'il ya une contribution
légère des familles cela permet de
récupérer la tva et avec ses recettes
nouvelles
on peut augmenter la qualité du service
et la mède partout de façon égale donc
le montant pièces dans les départements
où ces faits être entre 6 et 10% du coût
mais dumas caen petit chiffre précis
c'est la maman qui doit être apprécié de
façon globale
parce que vous allez l'imposer à tout le
monde que je comprends ce que ça va être
un problème huit départements des
fraudes mais s'est dit d'accord parce
que dans le département de la nièvre d
or de la nièvre le coût moyen
le coût moyen d'un élève est aux
alentours de 1800 euros
poulet parce que la qualité du service
et de la proximité très fort dans un
département où il ya la part du rural
est moindre là le coût peut être de 700
800 euros donc le fait de globaliser
permet de traiter différemment les
choses actuellement vous êtes assis ces
quelques de contribution moyenne mais
avec de grands écarts il y en a qui
payent beaucoup moins de mes doutes qui
payent beaucoup plus mais 6% sont
ramenés à la à 1800 euros comme en
moyenne una légèrement en dessous de
1000 euros par habitant mais cette
contribution ne naturellement belle
frappe aux oeufs lmp ni faire donc vous
venez ça veut dire que le département
s'est fait complètement gratuit père ont
maintenant des frais de dossier vous
l'avez compris si vous allez me dire ce
que vous en pensez dans mes chiens
d'apprendre quelque chose qui renversa
monsieur new vous venez de nous dire que
tous les départements vont maintenant
être traité comme l'yonne et comme la
nièvre puy de dôme
non monsieur miu miu vous n'êtes par
l'effort longuement laissez-moi la
parole 6% en moyenne dans votre
département madame c'est ce que vous
nous avez dit vous nous avez dit que la
contribution et les frais de dossier
représenterait environ 6 à 8% du prix du
transport
vous venez de le dire moi je vous ai dit
ce que j'ai entendu ce que je vous ai
donc c'est dans l'état actuel dès textes
pour pouvoir récupérer la tva et
améliorer nos mères tous les
défraiements améliorer partout il faut
que les frais mais aussi entre deux
jambes demi centre puisse nous dire ce
qu'elle pense de cette solution frais de
dossier monsieur ne dure qu'un temps
un programme électoral on va jusqu'au
bout vous n'aviez pas le droit de dire
que c'est sur les bancs des transferts
gratuitement et que tu dois la malraux
que dans notre département soit
préservée la qualité du service
elle sera augmentée madame parce que là
j'ai toujours avec l'autre coin gratuité
mais frais de dossier ce que ça vous
semblerait mieux ou pas acceptable donc
nous on veut on veut la gratuité on veut
que vraiment que ce soit ce choix
politiques de la gratuité soit mené aux
bouffes par par nos élus et voilà on
défendra vraiment jusqu'au bout sa
créativité c'est bien dommage c'était
annoncé c'est à dire gratuité du
transport mais frais de dossier pour
tout le monde ça vous semble le mieux
sauf que vous aviez vraiment l'âme du
scion pas accepter nous pour nous ça
changera pas grand chose qui ne changera
pas ce que ça diminuera parce que le
taux que je vous ai donné que le taux
pour récupérer la tva accueillir entre 6
et 10% sur une base moindre vous fera
diminuer la cour d'un moteur gâchette
menu h dans la galerie tonnes d'acide
bardon un échéancier une date du 18
rentrée 2009
nous sommes en compétences au 1er
septembre nous allons travailler sur
dès 2018 de suif aux jets en compétence
pour le faire et nous espérons commencer
progresser dans l'amélioration de la
qualité de service et d'aller le plus
vite possible dans l'harmonisation sur
les frais de dossier à la rentrée
prochaine 2002 la rentrée 2010 notamment
pour avoir des à-coups
n'y at her ce qui n'est pas bon qu'un
les 8 départements ou même dans les lui
département ont trait à partir de 2018
on va travailler sur ce sujet
l'animateur dévoile à lyon c'est pas
comme pour la taxe comme pour la taxe
sur les cartes grises où toutes les
augmentations monsieur antonio se font à
la hausse la qualité du service je vais
te augmenté partout merci à tous les
trois d'être venus débattre sur ce sujet
vous l'avez compris que tout fut
compliqué et techniques aussi rester
avec nous david rachline est l'invité de
francis se délier pour la deuxième
partie de dimanche en politique bon
dimanche
au revoir
[Musique]